tu élèves n'ont même pas de la qualité
d'image le fond c'est à dire que toutes
les deux sont kaka ses clients savent ce
qu'ils veulent
un téléviseur grand écran avec une belle
image l'objectif est simple se faire
plaisir avant le début de la coupe du
monde de football et le budget
conséquent 1000 euros avec la coupe du
monde qui arrive
j'ai une télé mais elle et elle est déjà
assez ancien j'aurais bien mis un doublé
pour regarder surtout la française
lorsqu'elle commence à fait un plaisir
là donc je pense que la coupe du monde
ce serait le top
mais s'il veut se faire plaisir pour la
coupe du monde avec un nouveau
téléviseur
voilà ça va se faire tout à l'heure dans
quelques minutes le temps de voir de
comparer les prix si vous regardez le
clip de fois jouer et vous gagne aussi 1
10 époux
complet de la coupe c'est pas la peine
dès l'entrée on comprend que le mondial
2018 est un événement majeur pour cette
enseigne une affaire sérieuse
à l'intérieur la décoration est en
rapport avec la coupe du monde jusqu'au
t-shirts des vendeurs rien n'est laissé
au hasard et la vente de téléviseurs
constitue l'élément phare de la
stratégie commerciale
l'udc ne privilégient l'idée est
vraiment de l'action de budgets des
clients c'est entre entre 500 et 800
euros
les notes vont au delà des moyens mais
ça m'a entre 500 et même son de cloche
dans cet autre magasin flambant neuf là
aussi les écrans géants sont
privilégiées par les clients en général
c'est sur les intermédiaires
donc nous allons d'une 108 points 123
est il qu'ils en sont prêts à mettre
sans problème
entre 700 à 800 euros et bien sûr il ya
le haut de gamme donc ils passent
directement à 1300 à 1400 euros par
rapport à la qualité d'image
la coupe du monde de football est une
opération rentable pour les différentes
enseignes spécialisées d'autant plus que
la technologie évolue rapidement effet
de téléviseurs achetés aujourd'hui un
objet de la préhistoire dans quatre ans
pour le mondial 2022